Do a little bit of work. I wanted to
play with this thing as well.
I think that this should now um
this should ask for perms.
Let's make sure this doesn't try to like
auto do stuff.
Let me see what tasks I have left.
for release
I know there's some junk in here.
No, but the rest of them are gone, so we
should be fine.
All right, so there's a little tiny bit
of blood on this.
Not bad though.
I might want to do some renames or
whatever.
I think it's not bad.
Yeah, this is super easy. Let's use this
to test the model.
This should ask for perms.
Oh, perfect.
This is exactly what we want, right?
I don't like how it doesn't have a
comment option.
Done.
Nice.
Hey Jess.
Yeah, this is going to be way better
than um cloud.
It's a very stupid model,
but it's very fast.
Oh, there's the tracker up there. That's
nice.
Very nice.
Yeah, this is definitely replacing
flood.
I think this is a much healthier
thing as well.
It's not really smart. It's not
pretending to be smart.
Just making these little edits.
>> New session.
Oh.
>> How are we doing this at the moment?
I think
>> You can let it do it in um
in bits like this.
What model are you using? This is GLM
4.7.
Uh the model is not the big deal though.
The big deal is the Cerebrus.
Why is this window so small? Like I
would want this to be
Is this a button? This is a button,
isn't it?
A little terminal you can plug things
in.
Huh.
That actually works.
That's bizarre.
Well, we'll see if it breaks it in the
process of doing this.
I think it's quite likely.
This variable might break.
And then I'll have to think about the
way we're using streams.
Oh, is it literally the same?
That's kind of awesome.
I wasn't sure we could treat the streams
that way.
Oh, it keeps it the same size, actually.
That's perfect.
I don't know why I did that. That's
freaking bizarre.
And this has been 16 cents as well so
far for this.
Nice.
Hit the works.
>> I do wish the screen would be slightly
bigger.
Like the edit window by default.
This be out of the article? Probably,
Jess.
I might make a little tweet about this.
And do this. That shouldn't hurt
anything, right?
What else is on my little list of
to-do's?
I don't know if this model will be good
enough to do stuff like write tasks.
We will see.
>> Oops.
Well, this will be super verifiable,
right?
>> That was actually quite good of it to
find.
>> Which model are you training?
>> I'm not training anything at the moment.
I'm debugging neural MMOs.
I'm debugging the neural MMO model.
Oh, this is just breakout of the test.
Let's see.
Payment required. I didn't think I'd use
that much um
I'd only used a couple bucks worth of
credits according to the
console.
Yay, instant. Works instantly.
Good job, Cerberus.
I didn't break this.
Let me commit these real quick.
Really liking this model.
Let me make sure the billing is actually
what I expect it to be.
I used 20
uh 18s. Ooh, wait, a dollar.
And
Okay, so the costs are not being
displayed correctly, it seems.
>> Interesting.
We'll monitor that and we'll see how
much um
us
Oh.
Just cuz it is test files, no biggie.
That's no biggie.
3.4 score
and 291 bill.
I don't think that's very good.
Right?
Yeah, I think this was the
This is at most 640 bill steps, probably
less.
Uh maybe it's around that, 640 bill.
So yeah, it's supposed to be way better,
way faster.
>> Let's have a go see if there's anything
obvious.
Tokens per minute limit exceeded,
really?
500k tokens?
This is 100k context.
The Cerebras is supposed to be $2 per
mil tokens.
Okay.
That's not good if I'm getting rate
limited that easily.
Open code any better than cloud?
Uh the point is not open code versus
cloud. The point is that it's Cerebras,
the hardware.
So, it serves like literally 10x plus
faster.
It'd be very surprising like if I had
the dims backwards
it should totally break.
Yeah, I'm getting rate limited very
quickly on this thing.
It should pet Wait, no, it's checking
both.
one or don't and they're able to take on
a lot more requests.
I just want this Arabesque model, Jess.
Um
Like this thing serves way faster.
I can probably use one of their other
ones as well if I don't want um
like the rate limits are too low.
Like let's say
there's like planner or whatever on here
as well.
Respect. I mean, this is how you debug
Like, I'm just basically going fishing.
I don't know if it's correct on the
transpose. We might just have a
different memory layout.
Okay, this does not have ocean in it.
That's fine.
Okay.
I was just making sure it's actually
re-compiling.
>> Oh, that's why it got stupidly
compressed.
Hey, what's up? Um hey, how's it going?
I'm basically I'm playing around with
this new model and I'm debugging a
couple of things.
Okay, that's actually pretty egregious
is the thing. How long have I been live?
hour
Eight bucks of credits already.
It's using way more tokens than it's
showing me then in the router.
So, they got
This is the
the most limited.
Where are their model pricing?
This one is 60.
It's a 16.
And then this is going to be a meme,
right?
Not even on there.
Yeah, so I think this is the only usable
model, right?
But why don't just
see
See, I
Yeah, that's actually So, I this is like
a decent enough model.
I think that I can't really switch to
anything else, though.
Cuz it's just like um
I think it just becomes unusable, right?
And nothing else here is served under
Cerberus.
That's not terrible though.
Uh,
um.
Is that on here?
I don't see it on there.
Uh, yeah, I mean that looks like it's
That's a nice bump.
The thing is for whatever reason it just
like eats tokens super fast.
That's just plum three.
Oh, did I do it wrong?
Yeah, it's plum three.
Yeah, they don't have it in um in
Cerberus.
They really got to get some better
models on here. I don't think it's their
main business is the thing.
>> It's actually kind of funny. I was
looking at their page.
You literally cannot buy um
you can't buy their plans anymore,
either.
Like they're just like, "Nah, we're sold
out."
Okay, this is just hooking in my actual
kernels, which is fine.
What did the plan include? It's the same
as everything else, just like, you know,
tokens per day.
It's like the standard that all the
companies do. It's like, you know, $50
of tokens a month gives you $50 of
tokens per day or whatever.
>> If this thing just bleeds a lot of
tokens, that's the thing.
Honestly, this is not
This is not good.
Yeah, this is way too complex of a task
for this thing.
Which app and equipment do you use?
Uh this is a restream at the moment, but
I'm probably going to swap that
tomorrow, honestly. I've had so many
problems with restream.
So, it does broadcast to multiple
platforms, but there's quite a bit of a
delay in there and some issues with it
as well.
This is not my main setup as well. This
is my kind of like jank setup.
I'll be back to my main setup Monday or
Tuesday.
Droid Cam
Well, yeah, I've got OBS.
I need something for restreaming,
though.
What's Droid Cam? Does that give you um
I need something for restreaming.
Well, to be fair, like this is this
section of code was messed by Claude, so
I can't figure out messed by
Claude.
Not this model's code. I wouldn't let it
touch this, but the ocean code was like
throwaway.
And I think the verification is wrong.
This is honestly way better, though,
because this is like
you run the thing, it fails, you do it
yourself. Not you run the thing, you
wait 15 minutes, it fails, and now
you're like bored and no longer in the
like the flow of things anymore, right?
Yeah, the encoder shouldn't have the in
dim.
Which is a void start. Should be a
neural memo 3 encoder.
From originally
the USA.
A guy in New England.
>> Yeah, this is kind of untenable,
honestly.
Might be able to just pull pull this in.
Colonels.
Yeah, the problem is needing this
encoder wrap at all.
I mean, this test is just ass.
Like this whole section of code is just
unusable garbage.
Yep, there we go. There goes the stupid
array.
Really stupid workflow.
It's better at least.
Just disgusting, man.
What a mess.
What Why do we not have an internet for
activations? What the is wrong with
this?
Where the does this thing get
called normally?
>> Okay, this is now just a bunch of
copies.
I mean, the thing is this whole thing is
stupid in the first place.
Yeah, I think I'm going to just call it
for a night for the night. I'm
exhausted. I've spent like 20 hours in
the last 2 days.
All right. Yeah, I'm going to just
follow you guys.
Um I'm going to do a couple last things
off stream and then I'm going to get
some rest.
Thank you all for tuning in.
Uh if you're interested in my stuff
generally, you want to support my work
for free.
Star the pepper on GitHub.
Helps me a lot.
And join Discord to get involved.
Tomorrow is my day off.
I probably will not stream and I will be
back
like Monday or Tuesday.
See you all.